made a compromise between better
protecting children
but also protecting privacy and data
it's detected through law enforcement
activities like covered investigations
but also by detecting communications by
providers
who are offering services like emails or
messages
we are clearly talking about unencrypted
content
in messages so we are looking into
images
into pictures text but we are not
following audio
[Music]
we are talking about the so-called
hashing technology
to identify already known pictures
images and videos
but we are also talking about
identifiers artificial intelligence
especially for checking cyber grooming
technologies who are not limiting their
technology to what is strictly necessary
to detect child sexual abuse are not
allowed
this legislation was created to allow
the
continuation of voluntary activities of
providers
to detect child sexual abuse material so
there is
no obligation for any provider to do
this
[Music]
we ensure during the negotiations that
the text is aligned with current data
protection legislation so we edit
safeguards like
better informing the user but also clear
data retention periods